we're now only a few days away from
Apple revealing their long-awaited
iPhone 15 lineup at their September 12th
wonderlust event but there's been a
glaring question that's poking into the
side of every iPhone user out there man
the 15 Pro is getting a huge redesign
with a bunch of changes and features
that everybody is getting hyped about
but should I just skip for one more year
what if the iPhone 16 Pro or Ultra is
going to be even better and I'll be
sitting there regretting that I upgraded
to the 15 Pro well if that's you I don't
blame you because we already know the
Pro Models are going to be getting even
more expensive by one to two hundred
dollars and to be completely honest the
new design still pretty much looks like
the 14 pro that we already have so in
this video I'm gonna help you by laying
out all of the new features and changes
we're expecting this year as well as
everything that won't get upgraded until
next year with the iPhone 16 lineup and
trust me there are some pretty in insane
changes including an even bigger display
and an even better super zoom camera but
before we get into explaining those
features let's quickly cover what's
coming to the 15 Pro and the pro Max
first of all these two models are
getting double the base storage 256 gigs
instead of the current 128 and we'll
likely see an upgrade to 8 gigabytes of
RAM to help with multitasking alongside
the new a17 bionic chip which will be
super efficient since it'll be the
world's first chip built on three
nanometer technology the most noticeable
difference will be the adoption of the
industry standard USBC port instead of
lightning which will lead to a bunch of
new advantages but it means you're gonna
have to buy new cables again but don't
worry Apple's going to be including new
color matched and braided cables in the
box that are now 50 longer than before
so quit your complaining just kidding go
ahead and complain but the biggest
benefit fits of the Pro Models will be
that the USBC ports will likely support
Thunderbolt which means much faster
transfer speeds that you can get on any
other Android smartphone out there but
you're probably going to need to buy the
Thunderbolt cable separately we're also
expecting to get a boost in terms of
charging speed up to 35 Watts instead of
the current 27 so if you want the
fastest charging you're gonna need to
buy a new power brick which I'm going to
link down below and as for the wireless
charging the 15 lineup will now allow up
to 15 watts with third-party G2 Chargers
but Apple might boost it up to 20 watts
with their own certified Max safe
chargers for the Pro Models the 15 Pros
will also be getting a metal frame built
out of titanium which will lead to a
significant weight reduction all while
reducing fingerprints compared to the
super glossy stainless steel that we
have right now oh and the edges are
going to be more rounded so they'll be
more comfortable to hold in your hands
instead of the old mute switch we're
going to be getting a brand new haptic
powered action button that'll be fully
customizable to open a wide variety of
apps or perform actions of your choice
like instantly opening the camera and
taking photos or turning on voice
recording while in your pocket other
than that not much else will change on
the outside except for larger camera
bumps which means lucky for Apple you'll
need to buy a new case on the display
side the edges of the glass will now be
slightly rounded merging into the
titanium frame in an Apple Watch fashion
and the display bezels will be much
thinner so it'll be more immersive and
as far as the cameras we're expecting
upgraded lidar sensors for better 3D
mapping and camera features and the pro
Max model will be getting a brand new
variable Zoom Periscope camera that'll
likely Zoom from 3x to 6 big sex without
digitally cropping which means killer
quality long range photos and videos
we'll probably get some spec updates
like Wi-Fi 6E and some other upgrades
like better speakers but other than that
not much else is changing now if that
wasn't enough to convince you to upgrade
this year let's go ahead and jump into
all of the new rumored features and
changes that you'll gain if you choose
to wait for the iPhone 16 lineup next
year the biggest change of all to look
forward to on the 16 Pro Models is a big
increase in display size from 6.1 inches
on the 15 Pro to 6.3 inches and from 6.7
on the 15 Pro Max to 6.9 inches this is
going to be a huge deal because the
regular 16 and 16 plus models are
rumored to keep the same display sizes
as they currently have which would
finally make the Pro Models look and
feel physically different now don't
worry about that crazy 6 0.9 inch model
being too big to hold in your hands
because apparently there were some
alleged leaked cads from Sony Dixon that
showed that apple is instead making the
display taller to give us that display
size upgrade without making the phone
wider so it'll still feel the same to
hold in your hands and yes Ross young
later confirmed that the 16 Pro Models
will have a taller 19.6 to 9 aspect
ratio and if you're wondering why Apple
would do this well according to Mark
German who confirmed the larger screen
leaks the whole point is to give the Pro
Models more internal space to allow for
major camera upgrades including a 12
inch larger main camera sensor and
finally putting the Periscope camera
into the smaller pro model and that's
exactly what makes you co said as well
that the 16 Pro would get the Periscope
thanks to the extra internal space but
here is the best and most exciting part
of all Mark German has said that if
Apple doesn't introduce the ultra model
this year then they for sure will use
that branding next year and that will
mean some extra features the biggest
standout feature of all is that Apple
will apparently give the 16 Ultra model
an additional super telephoto camera
this will apparently have a focal length
of over 300 millimeters which will make
it a 12x zoom lens which sounds
absolutely crazy so that camera will be
in addition to the new Periscope coming
this year on top of that RGS Cloud on
Twitter also leaked that apple is going
to be giving the 16 Pro Max or Ultra
model a huge upgrade in terms of camera
lenses introducing new hybrid lens
designs which combine the use of plastic
and glass elements across all the
cameras compared to right now where all
of the lenses are plastic so so it
should greatly improve sharpness going
further Ming shiko says that the 16 Pro
Models will be adopting a new stacked
camera sensor design that can capture
more light improving the low light
quality Jeff Pooh also liked that we
should expect a 48 megapixel Ultra wide
camera on the 16 Pro which is a huge
deal because there is a lot more area to
cover on Ultra wide lenses so if it
makes sense for any camera to have more
megapixels it's the ultra wide now
moving away from the cameras Mark
Goodman has said that Apple delayed the
new solid state haptic buttons until the
iPhone 16 lineup so we should expect
those to come next year the 16 Pro
Models are also expected to get upgraded
to Wi-Fi 7 which is great because it's
actually able to connect to two separate
bands at the same time so let's say 2.4
gigahertz and 5 gigahertz Wi-Fi bands
together to greatly improve reliability
without having to manually switch
yourself apple is also expected to
switch to their own custom 5G Modem with
the iPhone 16 lineup which should
improve efficiency and performance
across the board but here's one I'm
super excited about rjs Cloud leaked
that we were supposed to get larger
capacity batteries with the iPhone 15
lineup with apple using new stacked
battery cell technology but that has
apparently been delayed until the iPhone
16 lineup so we should see a big
Improvement in battery life next year
and finally the last leak we currently
have for this 16 lineup is the upgrade
to new micro lens technology which will
increase the brightness and efficiency
of the display so with all that said
it's pretty clear that the iPhone 16 Pro
Models are going to be getting a better
upgrade than we're getting this year
with the 15 lineup so if you don't care
that much about the titanium the US SBC
ports or getting that Periscope lens
right away then I'd probably suggest
waiting another year especially if
you're someone who only upgrades your
iPhone every few years so hopefully this
video was helpful and if it was you can
subscribe above for our coverage of the
Apple event next week and you can check
out every difference between the new
expected Apple watch models right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
foreign